nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
aujourd'hui direction le nord-ouest de
la Colombie Rafael Moreno y pratiquait
le journaliste citoyen inlassablement
sur sa page Facebook il dénonçait la
corruption des administrations locales
ainsi que les abus des entreprises
minières exploitant les ressources
naturelles de sa région le Cordoba dans
un pays où règne la loi du silence ces
enquêtes étaient suivies par plus de 50
000 personnes régulièrement il recevait
des menaces de mort il y a six mois il
avait pris contact avec forbidden
stories le consortium de journaliste
d'investigation basée à Paris Raphaël
Moreno souhaitait partager le fruit de
ses recherches avec des confrères
d'autres pays il n'en n'aura pas le
temps le 16 octobre il a été assassiné
par un tueur à gage France 24 avec
d'autres médias s'est associé à
forbidden stories suivant le mot d'ordre
qui définit le consortium vous pouvez me
tuer mais vous ne me ferez pas taire
c'est le projet Raphaël après plusieurs
mois d'enquête collectives la
correspondante de France 24 en Colombie
Pascal Mariani s'est rendu sur les pas
de Rafael Moreno dans une région marquée
par des décennies de conflits ce
reportage est aussi un hommage à ces
journalistes qui comme lui sont en
première ligne de la lutte contre la
corruption et les injustices
[Musique]
9 jours après cet appel Raphaël Moreno
est assassiné dans le restaurant qu'il
venait d'ouvrir pour arrondir ses fins
de mois
il laisse 4 jeunes enfants et une femme
Chiara
sa famille craint que le crime ne reste
un puni comme souvent en Colombie
[Musique]
[Rires]
ses amis le voyaient comme un
journaliste du peuple sa page Facebook
les voix de Cordoba étaient suivies par
plus de 50 000 personnes
[Musique]
principal de la mine de Sator
Rafael Moreno se présentait comme le
défenseur des ressources de sa région de
la corruption des politiques à la
pollution et aux abus des entreprises
minières il dénonçaient des affaires où
les perdants sont toujours les plus
humbles
c'est une malédiction de vivre dans un
territoire aussi riche que le Cordoba
c'est une malédiction d'avoir autant de
végétations d'avoir autant d'eau et en
plus d'avoir du charbon de l'or et du
cuivre
pour le peuple pour les gens ordinaires
c'est une malédiction
c'est une des voitures de l'entreprise
une multinationale basée aux États-Unis
a obtenu la concession minière d'une
vaste portion de la région
l'entreprise projette de creuser ici une
mine de cuivre à ciel ouvert
comme leurs opérations d'exploration se
font dans notre village il passe tous
les jours
300 familles vivent de leur paillage
artisanal autour de la Minelle à la
crâne installez-la depuis un demi-siècle
elles seront bientôt expulsées de ce
territoire
Raphaël Moreno connaissait bien cette
communauté de chercheurs d'or il y a
travaillé dans sa jeunesse avec son père
il leur rendait souvent visite et
relayait leur combat contre la compagnie
minière
Raphaël était d'ici et il a grandi ici
sur ce territoire
un moment il a commencé à diffuser des
informations depuis son téléphone et en
Colombie tout le monde sait que parler
de quelque chose vous expose
il s'est attaqué à tant de problèmes il
a dénoncé tant de choses qu'aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas qui l'a tué
mais la raison elle est claire
Rafa était une personne qui rendait
visible l'invisible
[Musique]
à l'image de la Colombie le sud de la
région de Cordoba est déchirée par de
multiples conflits
ce jour-là des manifestants protestent
contre la destruction par le
gouvernement des dragues illégales
placées sur les fleuves pour exploiter
l'or elles appartiendraient au clan du
Golfe le cartel tout puissant dans la
région les autorités accusent le groupe
armé d'organiser des manifestations de
mineurs menées par ces hommes cagoulés
travailler régulièrement avec Raphaël
Moreno comme lui il diffuse les
nouvelles de la région sur les réseaux
sociaux
le journaliste vit sous haute protection
après l'assassinat de Raphaël Moreno
l'Etat colombien lui attribué deux
gardes du corps et une voiture blindée
les deux hommes ont été parfois ensemble
sur des affaires de corruption
pour vous donner un exemple ils vont
faire asphalter une route et le contrat
se fait pour un million d'euros
donc il la font avec des matériaux de
mauvaise qualité ils investissent 400000
euros et vole les 600000 restants
parfois même ils ne font même pas les
travaux
ils prennent une photo ailleurs et font
comme s'ils avaient été faits ça
fonctionne comme ça
entre autres enquêtes Rafael Moreno
s'intéressait de près à la construction
du stade municipal de Puerto Libertador
les travaux lancés par la mairie en 2018
sont restés inachevés il l'avait
rebaptisé le stade de l'éternité
en Colombie les contrats publics sont
obligatoiresment publiés sur Internet le
journaliste examinait ceux de sa région
et les comparer avec la réalité
[Musique]
on raconte qu'autour de la maison
familiale les rues n'ont pas été
asphaltées en représailles contre son
travail
j'ai gardé une paire de chaussures de
Rafa et quand il referont la route je
les mettrai et je marcherai avec sur
cette route en son honneur
les menaces étaient constantes parfois
même contre moi
une fois il a reçu un message sur son
portable disant qu'il savait où je
travaillais et à quelle école allait
notre fils
dans toute la région
et il dénonçait différentes disons mafia
politique du département
et nous avions vraiment peur pour lui
à ses proches Raphaël Morino ne
racontait pas les détails de ses
enquêtes pour ne pas les exposer
lorsqu'il a commencé à faire ça personne
ne la famille n'était d'accord
absolument personne
de son vivant ils lui ont fait beaucoup
de mal beaucoup trop de mal jusqu'à
monter contre lui des groupes armés
combien de fois mon frère a dû
rencontrer les groupes armés pour se
justifier parce que l'ordre avait été
donné de le mettre hors d'état de nuire
Raphaël ne pouvait pas sortir en
discothèque parce que des petits cahiers
devenaient le voir pour l'agresser et
plusieurs fois ils l'ont battu
[Musique]
ce
en Colombie corruption et violence vont
souvent de pair
la mort de Raphaël Moreno a mis en
sourdine les rares voix qui les dénoncé
[Musique]
délicats
nous ne savons pas si c'est une
entreprise qui l'a fait tuer nous ne
savons pas si c'était une affaire
politique car nous avons attaqué à la
fois la politique et les entreprises
[Musique]
une source judiciaire lui fait part des
avancées de l'enquête
l'organisation c'est ainsi que surnommé
le clan du Golfe
ils ont arrêté une personne qui a parlé
elle a dit que ce n'est pas
l'organisation elle-même qui a donné
l'ordre mais que quelqu'un a payé un
membre de l'organisation pour le tuer
c'est terrible
le clan du Golfe qui se fait appeler
autodéfense gaëtaniste de Colombie AGC
et le principal cartel de la drogue en
Colombie il dispose d'une armée de
mercenaires et prélève sa part sur
toutes les activités lucratives des
mines au contrat public
le Cordoba est l'un de leurs fief
rien n'y bouge sans le raccord
cette vidéo d'une caméra de surveillance
a enregistrer le tueur à gage l'homme
entre dans le local ou le journaliste
est assis seul à monter Libano il tire
quelques coups de revolver et repart
effet
la voix de Raphaël Moreno s'est éteinte
mais c'est dénonciation lui survivre
[Musique]
voilà pour ce projet Raphaël cette
enquête internationale en hommage à ce
journaliste assassiné en Colombie en
quête que vous pouvez retrouver sur le
site de France 24 et celui de forbidden
stories c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur France 24